guess what Kelly told me last night she
and Ben are selling their home it's a
beautiful property
great location new kitchen I think
they'll give off the listing happy great
honey we can't be realtor's if we don't
have listings ah a casual life was
amazing but something happened to my
wife I can't feel my heartbeat what she
threw up this I didn't have formaldehyde
so I 15 olive oil that was a crazy
amount of ramen well I'm not a medical
expert it was a huge amount she's acting
different I can cook up for you
sweetheart I'm fine did mom die she is
dead and also under something I don't
like that word I think it's inherently
negative I don't like it either let's
not using I do like the way that I see
all my endless energy and I sleep 2
hours a night I get so much done you eat
people
I know existed I'm so much more
confident I can parallel park in one
move now the undead are completely
driven by their it but if I can't
control myself and I risk everything
that matters to me but then
that's any up to the colognes we are not
going to bail on you now we have to kill
so every desert
I guess the prototype would be a young
single Hitler God we'd be heroes
[Music]
yeah you guys are not great at this all
my life don't live or now on we [ __ ]
everything up together
yeah what kind of realtor are you
residential but commercial on request
[Music]
you
[Music]
so my wife's been on this new diet she
feels good look fantastic and had all
kinds of energy she is really happy so
it's all great well maybe not all great
you know there's some stuff going on
that's kind of intense like the other
day we were at the park she got hungry
and there's this jerk throwing rocks
with the Ducks
if you've tried all the other diets and
are looking for the one that really
works then the santa clarita diet is for
you lose as much weight as you want and
keep it off forever no gimmicks just
great results it's easy and your family
will love the new view but no one sauce
and you know the guy was been to the
docks the Santa Clarita diet it's great
get the first month free